everybody welcome back to another
mathematics and stock indicator tutorial
video in this video and the next few
videos we're going to be talking about
directional movement system or ATX for
short yet another one developed by mr.
Welles Wilder the idea of ATX as the
name suggests it's actually a system so
if you ever hear of like trading systems
usually they incorporate multiple
indications and stuff like that and this
is no exception it's a combination of
really three indicators I would argue
more like two indicators but three is is
officially the amount so the first idea
of it is first it determines if the
market is trending and then it provides
whether or not that would be an upwards
or down trend and even the strength of
that trend so it's quite interesting so
three lines are usually going to be
shown with the ADX you've got a usually
it's called a + di so this is going to
be your positive direction indicator and
it will see you later on we actually
call this a PDI
simply because you can't call a variable
you know the plus sign in Python then
you've got the negative Direction
indicator otherwise a negative di or in
our case it will be an N di and then
finally a geek a DX line this is going
to determine the strength of the trend
and so obviously the plus directional
indicator that's basically how many
moves up do we have and then the - di
how many moves down do we have and then
that gives you kind of whether or not
we're turning up or whether or not we're
turning down so the calculation of + di
+ - di is kind of like a multi-step
calculation so first you're going to
consider whether or not we moved up or
down and then so we've got you know
today's high which will denote as H in
our program
- yesterday's high which we would know
it is YH then we've got moved down
yesterday's low yl - yet today's low has
been L if move up is greater than zero
and greater than move down then the
positive direction move or PDM as we'll
call it is going to equal move up
otherwise PDM will equal zero
subsequently if moved down is greater
than 0 and greater they move up then the
negative direction move nd M equals move
down or nd M equals 0
finally again so that was plus DM or
plus like positive move right we still
haven't gotten to our plus di or minus
di so or rather the what we've got now
is plus DM or minus DM and we still need
to get to di so we're gonna assume a
window of 14 days you can obviously pick
whatever window you want but the plus di
or PDI is we're going to call it equals
100 times the 14 exponential moving
average of PDM divided by ATR and the
ATR is that average true range so what
we did in the last video series last
mini-series rather then we have the
negative Direction index n di or minus
di as you'll see it chart it often is
going to be very similar 100 times the
14 exponential moving average of the nd
M divided by the ATR so that's your plus
di + - di lines on the chart and in a
little bit I'll show you an example of a
couple examples of this stuff being
charted subsequently we actually
calculate the ATX finally the ADX is the
100 times the 14 exponential moving
average of the absolute value so we're
just looking for the difference here as
a positive number the absolute value of
the positive directional index - the
negative directional index divided by
the PDI plus the NDI and what that's
basically going to do is smooth it out
and normalize the data so it's all
normalized across no matter what the
price of that stock or what the Forex
ratio is all that next this is basically
how you would write it probe programming
Li
so if you're gonna follow us all the way
through the programming of this this is
more of what you're gonna see otherwise
if you just want to conceptualize it in
your head this is maybe an easier way to
conceptualize it so now let's go ahead
and look at some examples and kind of
discuss this so let me bring up the
chart that will be charting on here and
the first one let's see I think it's all
set up to be a 14 let me just check to
make sure yes this will plot a 14 ATX
across the board and the 14 positive
directional index of negative let's
start with Tesla will just peak at Tesla
see at Tesla's then since we looked at
that just not too long ago so this is
what we got here and so as you can see
I'm just going to fit this to your
screen a little bit here so as you can
see this centre line here the white line
is our ATX line the ATX signal lines is
the strength of a trend so as you can
see this trend this upward trend as it
continued going up and it kind of
slumped here the strength of the trend
did change and so again the ATX line is
just the strength of the trend so it
looks like it's following this line but
as this line continues to drop this
strength will actually probably start
going back up again if it does continue
to drop so keep that in mind that this
isn't it's just the strength of the
trend then you have the green line which
is our plus dir PDI and that is whether
or not that trend is a positive trend or
it's a negative trend so if we zoom in
to another spot like let's let's ignore
what's going on out here and look at
some of these trends in here and so as
you can see that as this was happening
here you could see that this the
negative was kind of going up and it did
cross over the green but then I started
going right back up again and then by
atomic meets the top here the green was
back and you know shown its face but
then it was already too late
it was going down so keep that in mind
obviously you're gonna see stuff like
that a lot of times the crossover that
marks a buy or a sell point
so maybe with Tesla with such volatility
with Tesla here you wouldn't want to use
a 14-day range alright so let's go ahead
and take a peek at another stock so
maybe let's look at eBay eBay is another
one that's been pretty volatile so be
interesting to see ok so here is our
eBay chart fit to screen
so here's eBay again and so here we can
see again here whether this is actually
a downtrend and as it continues dropping
the trend strength theoretically goes up
and then it kind of Wiggles around here
and kind of confuses us so the trend
strength starts to decrease because it's
like well this is no longer as strong as
it once was and sure enough as it goes
down far enough we can see the trend
does indeed change not only that but we
can see here where the negative
directional index is very strong it's
much stronger than our positive as it
hits this bottom as it starts playing
around here you can see this starts
actually losing strength same time the
trend starts losing strength so now
we're getting a signal that maybe the
trend is about to change
sure enough we get all three crossing
over right about here where positive
comes over negative goes down and this
comes down and starts changing its mind
about the direction it's going sure
enough we do get an upward trend so
that's the idea again we can see it
happening right over here so we'll zoom
in to this spot and then as you can see
as this continues going up we've got the
trend strength continuing and we've got
the positive directional index holding
you know positive then we've got a
crossover here sure enough we can see
that it's no longer as strong and the
trend strength continues going down so
actually overall pretty an interest
pretty interesting system say the least
so now what we're going to go ahead and
do is learn how to program this system
and then I'll show you how to go ahead
and plot it up on a chart just like this
one as always thanks for watching thanks
for the support the subscriptions and
until the next video